[Music]
[Applause]
Steve Palazzolo our good buddy Pro
Football Focus senior analyst co-host of
Pro Football Focus NFL podcast good to
see you again
have you guys chopped up the Super Bowl
and given out grades
yeah we have yeah it was uh we we do it
live pretty much and then review it the
next day so we got the grades out there
and the quarterbacks were as good as I
think they looked right Jalen hurts and
Patrick Mahomes two of the best players
on the field and the the grades
reflected that okay who had a higher
grade between those two
we had Hertz with a slight Edge in uh in
his overall grade obviously he had the
worst play with the fumble uh but in
Mahomes didn't really make a ton of
mistakes but Hertz had had more special
plays right some of those downfield
throws
um and some of his best throws were
incomplete the uh the Devonte Smith
passed down the field that gets dropped
or it just ends up being complete after
the review
um some nice tight window double
coverage throw a tight window throws to
Dallas Goddard another one on third down
after avoiding the blitz so uh Jalen
hurts was was awesome in that game and I
think we're gonna forget it though
because you know the Chiefs won but it
could lead to a big contract extension
because I don't know if people had
questions do you have questions now
after what you saw with Jalen hurts if
you were with the Eagles and you were
going to be handing out that check to
him would you have any issue giving him
45 million dollars a year
maybe 45 it's going to be fascinating I
would say
um the Eagles did such a good job
building their team this past offseason
because Jalen hurts was on that first
contract it allowed them to go get AJ
Brown it allows them to bring in a James
Bradberry they're going to lose a bunch
in free agency this year and it's going
to be difficult to replace those guys
because you know Jalen hurts is do the
next big contract so I do think he ends
up in that 40 million dollar range and I
do think the Super Bowl does go a long
way to uh you know it's still in
confidence of what he could do going
forward
if the Jets called you and said give us
the best quarterback that you guys have
graded that makes the most sense for the
Jets
who would you recommend
if you're willing to make the one to two
year investment I think it has to be
Aaron Rodgers you know I mean the the
other option would be Lamar Jackson if
you're if you if you want to trade with
the Ravens if they end up franchise
tagging him and you're going to give up
two ones I think the first option would
be Lamar Jackson just because you could
lock him up long term but I have to go
Aaron Rodgers over the other
Alternatives you know the Derek Cars of
the world the Jimmy garoppolos
um I think Roger's probably still gives
you that best one to two year option or
opportunity to win it and you're in an
AFC East that has Josh Allen in the
bills right it already has the dolphins
with their explosive offense I don't
think status quo and quarterback is
going to do it for the Jets yeah I said
I would rather have Derek Carr find the
Jets because I don't think they're ready
to I think they're ready to compete now
and maybe they're going to be a playoff
team
but I don't want the Aaron Rodgers
you're going to play for one year I
don't know about the next year because I
look at this as probably a three-year
window for the Jets where they can be
really competitive given the weapons
that they have I just I don't want to go
two steps forward and then two steps
back with Aaron Rodgers in two years and
then we got to look for another
quarterback
no I I completely get it it's just such
a fascinating time in the NFL though
right like when you have a guy like
Derek Carr who is you know quarterback
11 to 15 depending on how you want to
rank them right he's in that range what
a fascinating time where the NFL there's
a team that wants to move on from Derek
Carr but there's other teams who think
Derek Carr is going to be the Savior
right that's what happened with Jared
Goff with the Rams right the Rams had to
move on from Jared Goff who took them to
the Super Bowl the Niners did everything
to move on from Jimmy Garoppolo who took
them to a Super Bowl but for other teams
those guys are great so three years from
now the Jets might if they had Derek
Carr they might be saying uh we want the
next you know the next guy that's gonna
you know be better than [__] but what
about the Saints with Derek Carr
I think the NFC South might be a little
bit different I think every NFC South
team has been rumored to be looking at
Derek Carr because they're all saying
well Tom Brady retired the Bucks weren't
that good this year anyway we could go
win the division right I mean teams
still look at the short term and say
Derek Carr if he steps into that
division might be the best quarterback
there where he was the fourth best
quarterback on paper you know coming
into the the season in the AFC West so I
think it might be a little bit different
for a team like the saints that is
always uh always in credit card debt
when it comes to the salary cap they're
much more willing to make that type of
uh take that that type of investment in
a Derek Carr
it was strange going into this season
that Patrick Mahomes wasn't all pro the
previous year and it felt like he cooled
off a little bit then you had the Tyreek
Hill trade it felt like defenses were
playing a little softer keeping
everything in front Josh Allen loved Joe
burrow here Justin Herbert and and we
kind of forgot about Mahomes and that's
almost like forgetting about LeBron or
Steph Curry
why was it you know why do you think
that that we sort of moved on from
Mahomes or forgot about him
well because a year ago we did see
Mahomes War season you just described it
and not only that but an epic collapse
in the AFC Championship right they were
dominant in the first half against the
Bengals last year but we have never seen
Mahomes collapse the way he did in the
AFC Championship fumbles interceptions
that may not have been his fault but
just not leading The Comebacks that he
normally does not making that
game-winning drive it was his Worst
season right so understandably then you
lose Tyree kill and it was a fair
question to say how much of my home's
production is Tyree kill plus Travis
Kelsey plus Andy Reed in the system but
I think you have to hand it some homes
much like a Tom Brady Through The Years
Brady played in different systems with
different personnel and they always won
and they were always productive Mahomes
did that this year right he did it in a
different style it was a quick passing
game it wasn't the explosive plays down
the field he showed the patience He
adjusted to the league a huge part in
Mahomes career right now in year five as
a starter to just win in a different way
so I understand why people may have
doubted him a little bit but I think he
just answered all the questions and said
nope I'm Elite I'm the top guy and I'm
still here Steve paddlezolo he's the
senior analyst for Pro Football Focus
how bad was Russell Wilson's season
I mean by far his the worst of his
career he's he was one of the worst
quarterbacks in the NFL by our grading
system and pretty much any stat that you
use but I think that the really
difficult part too is when you go back
to about the middle of 2020. remember he
was having that incredible season on
Pace to break the touchdown record
middle of 2020 though things fell apart
2021 he was okay but then he gets hurt
wasn't good after the injury and then
last year was not good so we're talking
about almost a Year's worth of games
right now where Russell Wilson's been a
bottom third quarterback so it wasn't
just this year it was kind of the few
years before that coming so we'll see
what Sean Payton can do with them but it
certainly hasn't been great for the last
32 games or so of Russell Wilson's
career do you get enough of a sample
size with Brock Purdy to sign off on him
as the starter in San Francisco
to sign off a starter absolutely just
because you know you the the first year
contract type of stuff we hear that a
lot when you have a cheap quarterback
and
um it's Purdy in this system with Kyle
Shanahan not to take anything away from
Purdy he was excellent but Kyle Shanahan
has about a 15-year track record of
elevating every single quarterback that
he's played with from a production
standpoint they've all played better
um including when he had Matt Ryan the
best quarterback that uh Kyle Shanahan's
ever had Matt Ryan almost breaks the
league nine yards per attempt wins MVP
so I think a lot of it's The Playmakers
in the in the play calling in San
Francisco but Purdy was excellent
running that offense as a seventh round
rookie which is really impressive what
about Kyler Murray's grade and I know we
have to factor in the injury and is he
going to even be ready for this next
season
yeah so he was on this perfect
trajectory of getting better every year
his first three seasons it looked like
he had peaked uh he peeked in this in
his third year and this year he took a
big step back I don't know how much of
it was not having DeAndre Hopkins for
the first seven games but Kyler had the
highest percentage of Big Time throws in
the league in 2021 our highest rated
throws those special throws down the
field he was among the worst this year
so he wasn't pushing the ball down the
field at the same level his grade fell
back to about League average a little
bit below League average this year so a
lot of questions with Kyler and we might
not even see him for the majority of
next season because of the injury so it
was him progressing every single season
but definitely took a big step back here
in 2022. the bear situation you're on
the clock with the number one pick and
you have Justin Fields already
how did Pro Football Focus grayed out
Justin fields and what would you do with
that number one pick
so we created him as a below average
passer but unbelievable Runner right
exactly what we saw on the field I've
always thought he has the passing
ability so there's so much potential
there with Justin Fields I do think the
Bears should be doing their due
diligence on Bryce Young and the other
quarterbacks Bryce young in particular
he's the number one quarterback on the
PFF draft board I do think you have to
weigh taking Bryce young at one and
potentially trading Justin Fields I
think that's option number one
potentially if they like right you do
what would you do
I would I would I would take price young
and I would look to trade Justin Fields
I mean that's my that's my first option
if I have a good enough market for
Justin Fields the second option is trade
down and say okay we have to play up to
the Colts and the fact that they're
desperate the Panthers that they're
desperate the Raiders although maybe
even the Texans at two so you have to
trade down I think the worst thing the
Bears can do is draft a non-quarterback
the worst thing they could do is sit at
one draft a Will Anderson from Alabama
draft a Jalen Carter from Georgia they
have to maximize this first overall pick
either with a fresh rookie quarterback
or with multiple draft picks to
restructure that entire roster great
stuff as always Steve thank you for your
contributions this entire NFL season all
the great Folks at Pro Football Focus
thank you
you got it thanks Dad that's Steve
palazolo he might be the tallest analyst
covering the NFL